the conference on the future of europe
has entered the home straight
citizens panels representatives returned
to strasbourg they were joined by
members of the european and national
parliaments eu institutions and civil
society to fine-tune their proposals for
a better eu
finishing touches were put in
perspective by the war in ukraine
the citizens want the solidarity i think
this is the lesson we have to learn from
this we cannot have migration and asylum
policy without solidarity
ukraine featured heavily as conference
plenary debated democracy rights and
values and europe's place in the world
plenary also discussed the digital
transformation climate change and health
jobs and social justice
we bring you either an architect to come
faster and often workshop in line
in the larger
security
is set to meet once more before handing
final conclusions to the presidents of
the three main european institutions
conference organisers want to continue
the exercise in european consultative
democracy
the idea is in the future to have maybe
a permanent system so this is not the
end of this type of experience
[Music]
you